one idea that we're going to keep coming
back to in our study of government is
the notion of public policy and how
public policy is actually made
and what we're going to do in this video
is focus on what you could consider to
be the five stages of the policy process
and i'll use a very simple example to
make those stages tangible
so the first stage of the public policy
process is identifying issues or agenda
setting so agenda
agenda
setting
right over here are identifying issues
and an example of that and this is
actually something that is going on near
my house right now is that there is an
intersection about two blocks from my
house so let me see if i can draw this
intersection
so
looks something like this
and it's a two-way stop sign so
you have a stop sign right over there
you have a stop sign right over there
and
the problem is you have this large park
in this corner right over there and
there's also a school here and so in the
morning there's a lot of kids and
parents going on their bicycles or
walking to school but the problem is
there's also a lot of parents who might
be late for school and they're going in
their cars and they're going quite fast
down this road and it's a two-way stop
and so even though that there's a lot of
kids that are waiting to cross right
over here and there's no crossing guard
so there's a lot of kids and parents
walking around a year they have to wait
and you can imagine this is an
elementary school these cars are going
by really fast it's quite dangerous so
the agenda here is is that well how do
you how do you make this safer and
easier for families to cross the street
on the way to the park so the example
here how
to make
easier
to cross
the street
at that intersection
now once you determine the problem that
you want to solve you do the agenda
setting the next step is to formulate
some type of a policy so i'll call that
step two would be policy
policy formulation
so one potential idea here is well why
don't we just make this into a four-way
stop so we could put some paint here to
make it clear that people are going to
cross on all sides and we'll put two
more stop signs to make this a four-way
stop
so let's say that this is
our current plan as we say hey making
this tangible we're going to implement a
four
way
stop at that intersection now not that's
not the only solution that's possible
maybe some type of speed bumps might be
in order right over here and right over
here maybe there implement some type of
crossing guard or maybe
you put one of those flashing blinking
signs that tell people their speed limit
so that they go slower so there's many
different ways to formulate ideas that
will address this agenda that will
address these problems but let's say
that we do a study and we decide that a
four-way stop is the policy that we want
to pursue
well then the next step after that is to
convince other people that this is a
good idea
so step three right over here
we could call
policy
policy adoption
adoption
or legitimization and in my context it
might involve going to the city council
maybe with some traffic experts some
safety experts maybe i can go gather the
community here petition so that a lot of
people in the community here agree that
a four-way stop would be in order and
let's say the city council and the
police department and all the various
stakeholders who have to buy in say yes
we are going to implement a four-way
stop here and then they implement it
and so once the policy is adopted the
next thing is well you gotta actually
implement it so i'll call that step four
policy
policy implementation
implementation
augmentation and in this case it's
pretty straightforward someone needs to
show up and install those stop signs
maybe they're gonna paint put some
markers over here to make it clear more
clear that people are going to cross the
street as they go on to the park but
that would be the implementation now the
last step in this public policy
cycle or this process and we'll see it
really is a cycle is to just assess it
to evaluate how things are going
so the next step we'll call this step
five right over here would be policy
assessment
assessment
or evaluation
and so one possibility is to go survey
people in the community has that solved
the problem
has it created new problems is there a
traffic issue now because people have to
go to the four-way stop and whatever the
assessment says the assessment might say
hey everything's perfect now and then
you don't really have to worry about the
this problem anymore but maybe there's a
new traffic problem and now that would
be another issue to address and you'd
have to go through the cycle again or
maybe it hasn't addressed the speed
issue and so maybe you need to think
about well how do we slow cars down or
whatever else and we would keep going
through this public policy process or
this really this cycle that we're
talking about now the example that i
just gave this is a very simple example
at my at a corner two blocks from my
house and this is actually something i'm
thinking about i'm thinking about going
to the city council about this
but as you can imagine as we go into
much deeper things that are affecting
people at the federal level health care
taxes whatever else
each of these steps can be quite
involved and it could even take years to
do any one of these steps